hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden's national polling lead
slightly shrinking while he continues to
hold an edge over the president
in several swing states eric trump
executive
vice president of the trump organization
joins the rundown to discuss the 2020
race
how it compares to the 2016 election and
why he says he does not trust
the polls and michigan congressman dan
kildee says he believes the president
has lost the trust of americans when it
comes to dealing with the coronavirus
pandemic
the democrat weighs in on the ongoing
health crisis the upcoming presidential
debates
and the importance of michigan in the
presidential election
plus commentary by author lawyer and
orthodox rabbi sam bregman
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm maria bartiromo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
liz clayman
and this is the fox news rundown
friday september 18th 2020.
i'm dave anthony the president and joe
biden will both
campaign in the same battleground state
where polls have the democrat
in the lead not a concerned eric trump
they got it wrong in 2016. i think
they're going to get it wrong again
in fact i see more enthusiasm in 2020
than i did in 2016 to tell you the truth
i'm lisa brady democrats have seen this
movie before too
and some of them aren't willing to trust
the polls either
i don't think anyone can take anything
for granted it's going to be close
and we're going to have to finish the
race and i'm rabbi sam bregman
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
early voting starts today in a state
that has gone democrat blue
in every presidential election dating
back to 1976
but this year the trump campaign thinks
it has a shot at winning minnesota
so the president will hold a rally
tonight in bemidji
the left has launched a vicious and
violent assault on law enforcement
reiterating his law and order message
dating back to protests turned riots in
minneapolis
after george floyd's death in an
encounter with police whether it is the
mob on the street
or the canceled culture in the boardroom
the goal is the same to silence dissent
to scare you out of speaking the truth
the president at a constitution day
event
at the national archives museum on
thursday
patriotic moms and dads are going to
demand that their children are no longer
fed
hateful lies about this country joe
biden
will campaign in duluth minnesota today
as the democratic nominee releases two
new ads in battleground states
addition to bringing back the jobs has
been lost this year
my plan will help create at least five
million new
good paying jobs in manufacturing and
innovation his second commercials
message
is very different yeah i voted for uh
trump in 16
then i'll be the first to tell you i
made a mistake
he's a farmer in pennsylvania you know
president trump uh he's not responsible
for his virus uh nobody was going to be
able to stop that but he was
totally negligent on how he uh informed
the people
i mean the guy the guy gets the blame
for what's happening
now the trump family is out campaigning
trying to counter that message
i have to say pretty much everywhere
we're going the energy is like beyond
good i mean every
every time we have a rally every time we
have an event four or five six hundred
people show up we caught up with eric
trump in new hampshire the enthusiasm
out there um
you know for make america great for for
my father it's uh it's unbelievable i
mean it's really it's
a beautiful thing to see no a lot of
those states your father won
in 2016 but in the polls he has been
shown to be
behind joe biden from arizona to
new hampshire to florida and michigan
and a lot of those places does that
bother you worry you at all
you know it's uh we always watch the
polls and and i always watch polls i
also read the back up to a lot of the
polls and um you know it's interesting
we faced the same thing in um
in in 2016 where i'd be in pennsylvania
and i'll just give you a great example
and you'd
see you know 200 trump signs you'd be
driving through you know
pittsburgh or you know some area you'd
see here 200 trump signs and then
you'd get home and you'd be watching tv
and you know some pulse or somebody on
uh you know one of the big channels
uh would be you know telling you that
you're down by uh you know 10 points
there and you're saying they're saying
uh
this doesn't make sense right i just you
know spoke in front of thousands and
thousands of people
you had people you know literally waving
the american flag you had people in mega
hats you had babies dressed
up in uh babies for trump and you know
we're we're gonna lose and then
we'd be driving down the road we come
across a barn you know um
you know literally you know trump 2016
now i'm seeing a trump 2020 and
or you know a family literally spent a
week out there painting the thing that's
how much enthusiasm there was and
we're seeing none of that provide and we
saw none of that for hillary and
you know yet they would always tell us
that we were behind in the polls and um
you know they got it wrong in 2016. i
think they're gonna get it wrong again
um in fact i i see more enthusiasm in
2020 than i said in 2016 to tell you the
truth and it's uh
it's uh it's unbelievable some of the
stuff that we're seeing out here in the
fox poll that came out the other day
joe biden's favorable rating in your
father's favorable rating are
inverse joe biden is 54 favorable your
father has 46 percent favorable
so how for those who who don't view your
dad favorably what do you try to tell
them how do you try to change their mind
you know how much i love uh i love fox
and you know you know much i love some
of the
the hosts on fox but for whatever reason
that the fox polls have been some of the
worst and some of the you know least
accurate polls and i you know i just
have to say it and um
you know you guys are an incredible
network but your polling has always been
um
beyond bad and um you know what do i say
i don't know i i think a lot of
republicans aren't polls i think a lot
of republicans don't pick up the phone i
think a lot of republicans
um you know um you know sometimes are
fresh and
and and frankly lie i can't tell you how
many people you know i've spoken to yeah
i got i got pulled for the first time
well
you know who did you say you're voting
for i said i was voting for biden
because i don't
yeah i don't want them to know who i'm
actually voting for and i didn't care to
tell them
and um you know what i can tell you is
the enthusiasm out there just just look
at all the signs i mean you know forget
about forget about these nonsense polls
that are typically done by people that
have you know some motivation one way or
the other
uh look at these signs look at the boat
parades look at you know these
you know you have 15 000 people on an
average weekend right in clearwater
florida that are going out there flying
the american flag and flying the trump
2020 flag i mean
look at these um you know rolling
thunder these motorcycle rides and then
look at the crowds that we're all
pulling in in these states my wife
myself
don ivanka when we go to these states i
mean it's the love out there is
unbelievable it's it's um
it's tremendous and and and those are
the only polls i need to uh i need to
see and
you know then look at other kind of
quantifiable metrics i mean last month
my father's campaign website had 16
million people 16 million people visited
it right whereas
biden's website had three million people
visited right i mean we could go on and
on with little statistics like that i
just
i see some of the fox polls with the
sample set of 400 people and i just i uh
i normally question the results because
it's um you know for some reason they've
never gotten it right and i think
they're getting it wrong again right now
the one thing in the poll that you
probably would like
is that more people view your father as
a
better steward for the economy than they
think joe biden how much when you go out
how much is your message about the
economy
well it's a it's a massive part of my
message because i don't think there's
ever been a better economic presence
than my father i mean
you know i implore anybody listening
right now open your 401ks open your iras
open any pension plan you might have and
look how much it's up and then you know
dave in the
in the eight years of of obama and biden
um
the dow jones went up by four thousand
points in the three and a half years of
my father the dow jones has gone up by
twelve thousand points so if uh
you know i i love hearing uh you know
these comments from him oh we created a
great economy know our father's created
a great economy and
you know that's what happens when you
cut taxes and you cut regulation and
you become a great cheerleader for this
this nation and um
and uh you know you look at what biden
wants to do biden wants to increase
taxes by four trillion dollars you know
what they'll do to our markets i mean
you know our markets will will literally
tank um
you know if he ever if he ever gets in i
mean could you imagine how devastating
that be for the united states four
trillion dollars
a year in extra taxes for this nation i
mean that would literally
um bankrupt so many companies bankrupt
so many people
um and it would just be a disaster and
um but they're trying to get rid of the
tax cut that they say
that wasn't necessary that helped people
who were
the high end income and helped companies
businesses that don't pay their fair
share is what their
argument is yeah well 82 percent of
people would have their taxes go up so
effectively that's everybody in the
country that pays taxes um
you know 82 percent of people would have
their taxes go up under um you know buy
tax cuts and you know the reason you had
3.6 percent unemployment in this country
3.5
unemployment in this country is because
you know cut small business taxes and
they could
they could hire more people and they
could invest in their companies as
opposed to getting choked off by taxes
and
you know obviously we did something
right i mean you know during most of the
obama administration you had
substantially higher
uh unemployment than you do during this
period of covid i mean if you could
possibly believe that and
um you know when you see 10.4 million
jobs return to an economy in 90 days
and um you know the markets are
skyrocketing again i mean there's
tremendous confidence in this country
and
that should make every american
incredibly proud during the second term
for president obama on average there
were more jobs per month
created than in the first three years of
your father's administration this year's
crazy of course with the virus
so when you say that the obama
administration didn't do very much but
in job creation they did lead your dad
on average
in their four years versus three i don't
know about that
obama sent every single job out of our
country look at the factories that close
look at the industries that were
decimated um under obama look them i i
i would i would highly contest that
number but
you didn't see wage growth under obama i
mean you had stagnation under obama
you had 0.9 gdp growth um
under obama i mean you know wages
weren't going up
um at all in fact wages hadn't gone up
in 10 years in in this country
um you know there was total stagnation
of wages so
um you know just to say he was a great
jobs president is just
not the case he had the slowest recovery
coming out of our recession in the
history of our nation
um you know that's a fact dave i mean
it's just it's a it's a fact you know
they crippled industries all across the
country i was in
minnesota talking to loggers um the
obama administration absolutely crippled
that industry as well i could go on and
on and on but
um eric your dad's critics also say that
he
he he ignores science you know climate
change with wildfires
and the corona virus that uh he's
constantly battling doctors on the
coronavirus what's your response when
you hear that
no i think my father realizes that
there's you know competing forces at
play and both of them have to be taken
into account
um the virus was very serious and that's
why he shot down the concrete he did it
while
uh joe biden was calling him xenophobic
for closing down travel
to china at the same time with the
largest economy in the world by far
um and you can't shut down our entire
economy for the rest of eternity
um where people don't have jobs and
businesses are closed and people can't
provide for their families
um there are competing forces and both
of them have to be taken to account
you know um you know biden came out the
other day said yes i would i would
reshut down
the economy i would reshut down our
country
i mean that is that's a scary
proposition i mean you've got families
out there that depend on
i mean everybody that depend on their
jobs to feed their families to provide
education to their children
um you know that they need a livelihood
you have to open up restaurants you have
to open up
um you know shopping centers you have to
open up our
our country once again gyms and this and
that i mean
you know these people provide for i mean
this is the united states of america we
can't be closed for the rest of eternity
and um
you know so my father is a big believer
in science but he's also
a pragmatist right he you know he
believes that you have to have a viable
economy in this country and we can't
just leave america closed in perpetuity
all right you go out campaigning for
your dad 2016 here again in 2020.
you ever want to do this for yourself
run for office someday
honestly it's um you know i really mean
this it's it's it's uh it's a brutal
um it's not a business but it's uh it's
just a brutal uh profession it's um
you know it's it's tough it's it's it's
nasty the people in washington dc uh you
know the vast majority of people aren't
aren't good people uh the mass
vast majority of politicians there's you
know so many horrible people in in the
profession
um you know so it's okay being up for
your dad but
you don't want to do this for yourself
so much yeah i i don't know i i would
certainly if my son ever came to me and
my daughter and said listen i really
want to run for office i'd probably
discourage them from doing it it's just
it's um
it's it's nasty um i always thought real
estate was the toughest industry in the
world they always said it was you know
their babies compared to some of these
politicians the lies that they make up
and the way they try and go after people
and the way they try and take people
down just look what they did to justice
kavanaugh i mean
they made up lies they tried to destroy
the man look at these
tony dossiers look at the way they
weaponize the you know
legal system in this country look what
you know i mean they weaponize
doj and the fbi and i mean it's a
horribly nasty business at the same time
i'm so proud of what my father's been
able to accomplish him and he's done
more in three and a half years and i
think any president
history and um you know the sacrifices
he's made for the for the country uh for
a country that we love
and you know red white blue which is
what we love is um
is tremendous so um i don't know um
you know i i believe he's done a
phenomenal phenomenal job but it's um
it's it's uh it's certainly a tough uh
you know it's
politics is rough in this country
especially on the level that we uh that
we play at
and it's um it discourages a lot of
great people from going into it
based on the antics of of so many
involved
well i'm sure we'll see a lot more on
the campaign trail eric trump thank you
so much for joining us
thank you
[Music]
this is rabbi sam bregman with your fox
news commentary
coming up while the president and his
campaign
praise his record and defend his
coronavirus response
democrats are assailing his leadership
and his character
monstrous is the word used by senate
minority leader chuck schumer
after the president's reference this
week to death rates in
blue states if you close your eyes and
pretend that half of the country doesn't
exist
maybe some might think you didn't do
such a spectacularly awful job
the race does appear to be tightening
though and while the biden campaign
makes more trips to battleground states
his supporters are also taking notice
i'm very cautious about
overreading or over interpreting the
polls
representative dan kildee is a four-term
democratic congressman
from michigan we've been through this
once before in 2016
where you know the president never
really had a lead
until election day and won michigan by
ten thousand seven hundred
and four votes so you know these polls
are a snapshot
of who we predict will vote on any given
day
and we don't really know yet who will
show up so i think
they're accurate in terms of the people
they're polling but the real variable
that we look for is what's the level of
enthusiasm
for trump supporters what's the level of
enthusiasm for biden supporters that's
the biggest variable so
you know i i will say we're going to
work to the very end obviously i support
vice president biden and we're just i
don't think anyone
can take anything for granted it's going
to be close and we're going to have to
finish the race
michigan is one of the states where
there were protests over lockdowns
so i'm wondering you know is joe biden
out of touch a little
with michigan voters working class
voters when he criticizes the the
president's
push to reopen not at all
not at all the fact that people have
disagreements
over the measures that the governor took
shouldn't be read as a lack of public
support but just the diversity of
opinion most people that i speak with
and you can look at the polling most
people in michigan
support the measures that the governor
took
so i mean i don't think he's out of sync
i think he's actually quite aligned with
the people that i know
who are very concerned about coronavirus
want to make sure that the proper
measures are being taken
and have seen the approvals for this
very same governor that
the president has been criticizing the
approval rating for
that governor is far above the approval
rating for the president in michigan so
i think joe's
message is not only correct from a
health standpoint
but it has the additional value of being
aligned with the thinking of the people
of michigan or at least the majority of
them
he does face criticism from time to time
that you know for not really saying
exactly what he would do
differently you know he gets accused of
saying things that actually have already
been done
or even stealing the president's ideas
for something like the
you know push to buy buy american uh
made in america
that initiative um but even on the
pandemic he's he gets accused of
where are the specifics you're not
really saying what you would have done
differently do you does that worry you
at all is that something that that
concerns you heading into the final
weeks of the campaign
no because i don't accept the premise um
i've spoken to joe i've been
in meetings where joe is is actually
quite clear about how he would
operationalize the defense production
act for example to make sure that we
have adequate ppe
so you know actually at the outset of
your question i thought you might have
been referring to
president trump because very often he
says things but doesn't follow through
on them or says something that simply
you know turns out not to be the case
and i get it
people who are opposed to joe biden are
going to find every way and every reason
to
find something he said and find fault
with it in this very difficult time
i guess the same is true for opponents
of president trump
but when we step back from all of this
you know the people i represent and the
majority of people in my state
don't feel that the president has
handled this very well at all
and would prefer someone who would just
simply level with him
i mean mr biden certainly does spend a
lot of time attacking the president
though
um you know as opposed to really talking
about policy proposals
and does that hurt you know down ballot
democratic candidates because i know
some have started breaking
with his campaign's more cautious
approach and have actually started going
back
to knocking on doors um wearing masks
but but knocking on doors
um kind of trying to get back out there
and campaign a little more
aggressively um so is it you know
do voters really know what he stands for
aside from
being completely and totally vehemently
opposed to the president
well again i think they do i mean when
joe was in michigan
um a little over a week ago it was to
lay out a very specific set of policies
and you know i guess this is all sort of
in the eyes of the beholder
i suppose because the people that i talk
to and the people back home see if
pretty differently um when like for
example you mentioned
uh bringing uh jobs back and you know
the buy american initiative uh that that
vice president biden laid out it was a
very specific
set of tax incentives and proposals that
i think makes sense i'm on the ways and
means committee
uh the tax writing committee and what he
was saying makes
perfect sense so it's more than a slogan
it's
policy so and on that point you know i
think i think the vice president
is laying out a vision on this issue of
the tactics of the campaign
i think there's a real conversation
going on right now
um personally i don't believe that the
the uh the campaign tactics that the
president has engaged in
are helpful or safe there were you know
over 5000 people
packed into freeland michigan
almost none of them wearing masks that's
probably not a good idea
but to be fair i think there are ways to
get out there
to knock on doors in a safe fashion
wearing masks
to be careful that we're going to have
to explore because
the cautious approach i think from a
public health standpoint is justifiable
but maybe there are some things that can
be done
that are safe that also allow the kind
of careful direct voter contact
that campaigns traditionally engage in
so we're looking at that
many times voters elections do come down
to
the economy as the overriding issue you
know is their household
better off than it was four years ago i
mean why shouldn't voters think that the
president
could deliver on building a great
economy
again and at the same time i want to
circle back too
because you mentioned biden's tax plan
he always says no one with income of
400 000 or less is going to see an
increase in their federal taxes
but there is some concern that it would
have a broader
impact that people you know beyond that
income range
might take a hit from his proposals
something like you know four trillion
dollars worth of proposals
so how do you you know balance out those
arguments
to voters well i think we just have to
look at the record i mean
we have a tax bill that was signed by
president trump
that granted huge benefits to the people
at the top
it obviously was disproportionate in the
benefit that accrued 83
of the benefits going to the top 1 i
think
what i've heard from vice president
biden is not that we just throw it in
reverse and go back to
the previous tax code to try to find
some balance
so that uh we are able to manage
the uh the fiscal condition of the
country and of uh the federal government
but that it's fair i mean they're just
far too many people far too many
corporations in this country
to pay zero zip zero nothing in taxes
and that's not right that's just not
right just plainly wrong
that has to be addressed and that's one
of the things you know i'm again i'm on
the tax writing committee so it's a
subject that i'm
somewhat familiar with i think that is
something that most americans
uh reject i have to sneak in one last
question about the upcoming
first debate because um
that's going to be interesting seeing
the two of them going one-on-one
together um the former vice president
does take heat for making gaffes
and just recently he and running mate
kamala harris
both made reference to the harris biden
administration instead of the biden
harris
administration do you are you worried
about those kinds of things
at all do you hear any concern coming
from your constituents about that
no i mean that's i mean honestly i think
that's
a little bit like people complaining
about barack obama wearing a tan
suit uh if if we really are going to
have a debate let's
let's be fair about this if we really
are going to sort of stack up
the gaffes that joe biden or anybody
else may have made when everything
you're saying is being recorded you're
going to
you know say some things that might not
come out right
if this comes down to a race that is
determined by
the gaffes that everybody wants to make
uh
you know attempt to pay attention to the
vice president biden
might have done you know this is just
part of who he is
against the litany of tweets
of statements of misstatements
of outright you know demonization of
people
of name calling of childish
rants by this president i'm willing to
have that be
the measure of the two candidates and
let it go at that
worried at all about the debate no i
mean i think
it's going it's the way i see it it's
going to be an opportunity for people to
look at both of these
uh candidates listen to what they have
to say and and make a judgment as to who
they want to have lead us
going forward out of this coronavirus
pandemic and into the future michigan
congressman dan kelsey thank you so
so much for your time thank you i really
appreciate it
[Music]
it's the perino and stirewalt i'll tell
you what podcast dana perino of the five
and fox news political editor chris
stirewall dissect the ins and outs of
national politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
we're still more than a month away from
halloween but fans of the holiday are
already thinking about their costumes
the decorations and if trick-or-treating
will be a possibility this year with
covet 19.
but one man in cincinnati has come up
with a way to hand out candy
in a socially distanced fashion andrew
beatty usually goes all out with a decor
for halloween and since the coronavirus
pandemic has brought with it the need
for social distancing
he and his daughter have invented a
candy shoot for just that reason
thought this would be a good year with
everything going on right now in the
world to
put something together he says they were
able to use things around the house and
put it together in about 20 minutes
the chute is a six foot long by four
inch wide cardboard shipping tube
painted orange and decorated with black
tape
he fixed it to the railing of his front
steps and he's even wrapped it with
strands of halloween themed lights
trick-or-treaters put their bucket under
the bottom of the tube
and i'll be having gloves or tongs and
pulling out fresh candy from a freshly
opened bag and dropping it down the tube
the little ones will hold their
trick-or-treat buckets or bags right
here and
it'll fall into the bucket or bag he
posted his idea on facebook and so far
it's been shared more than 80 000 times
betty also points out the touch free
candy shoot may also make things
easier for those with mobility issues as
it doesn't require navigating stairs
every year i dress up like michael myers
or something of that nature and you know
you got a lot of little kids that are
afraid to walk up to someone like that
and then you've got people with
strollers people with wheelchairs things
of that nature
there's already some struggles when
you've got something like this to
navigate so
it's already an idea that was i think
waiting to happen and
this just was kind of the catalyst to
kick it off special thanks to fox 19
now's brittany harry who reported the
story
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
rabbi sam bregman
what's on your mind for jews around the
world
this weekend begins the annual high
holiday season
beginning with the jewish new year of
rosh hashanah followed by yom kippur
the day of atonement 10 days later
against the backdrop of the coveted
pandemic
for many jews this will be a most
unusual season of observance
this will be the first time in their
lives they're unable to attend the high
holiday synagogue service
or gather with family or friends just as
the restrictions on public worship
were difficult for christians worldwide
this past easter
so too this holiday season will pose
unique
pandemic related challenges for jewish
people
of course the peculiarities involved
with synagogue worship
this year aside the messages of rosh
hashanah and yom kippur
remain timeless ones for people of all
faiths
these holidays are deeply affiliated
with the idea of personal renewal
and the ability for a human being to
chart a fresh course
in life in particular this fresh course
is in the area of deeds of kindness and
selflessness
towards our fellow man what is the
source for this
the torah explains that since rosh
hashanah correspond to the sixth day of
creation in the bible
the day that god created adam and eve it
thus becomes an
annual inflection point to contemplate
the lives we've been living in our
public
and private lives and to pivot as
necessary
it's axiomatic there's basically two
types of people in this world
those that are self-centered and those
that are other
centered while of course every person
needs to take care of himself
there is also a unique soulful pleasure
that comes from bettering the lives of
others around us
and multiplying our own involvement in
acts of kindness
although that sounds quaint to some
people and it plays an attenuated
mutated role in our society
every person can avail himself of the
sweetness that accompanies a life
focused on goodness and kindness it only
takes a willingness to do so
because there is more to life than our
own aggrandizement
our behavior and choices really do have
consequences in this world
and against the backdrop of this highly
divisive time in our nation
let us pray that we can all redouble our
commitment to being truly good to one
another
and multiplying our love of good deeds
with all my heart i wish you a beautiful
happy sweet new year and i would jewish
leaders around the world
wish that everyone should be sealed in
the book of life for a prosperous
healthy and meaningful year as we recite
in the high holiday prayer book
let the year and its curses conclude and
let the new year
and its blessings begin
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app
and just click listen when you swipe
left you can listen to your favorite fox
news talk shows live swipe right for the
latest fox news radio newscasts on
demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes